c'est la bonne position pour le oui non
je pose des questions faut pas répondre
par oui ou par non à temps on va partir
pardon c'est une minute attention si tu
perds j'imagine enlève sa magie
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir comment ça va ça va bien pas mal
sportivement on dirait un bon centif ça
m'arrive je fais du sport smart a déjà
un petit peu pas en quoi ce matin et le
soir peut-être après le sacre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir ça va est-ce que tu peux
regarder
exact c'était tout jeune alors très
jeune tapeta région parisienne pas loin
marié pas encore amoureux peut-être
j'aimerais bien elle est pas là non
[Rires]
y en a pour tout le monde j'avais beau
me concentrer sur ce que je vais dire la
personne y avait trop d'informations
n'est pas un truc à la partie des
attaquants dans blow il paraît
absolument pas mais n'avait pas cuisiner
je déteste cuisine et quel est votre
plat favori
mon plat favori c'est les eaux les 10 à
20 heures c'est bien vous avez joué là
je crois j'ai bien joué j'entendais
quand j'entends je parle c'est fort je
parle
oui
on
tellement vrai
bonsoir mr mat grande cravate de couleur
tous les jours une cravate après jour
ces motos s'il a vraiment ça se sente
gêne pas jamais sur un certain certains
certains individus comme en voiture
à votre avis le permis de conduire à la
rumeur détendez vous vous vous rangez
rien du jeu c'est pas assez forts passés
combat c'est faux je n'ai ça va très
bien dit valérie jamais d'avis frei et
tire larigot le des réseaux si jamais si
mains fréquemment tous les soirs au
prince parce que le tout les soit
presque mais pas tout le temps quand
même pas tout le temps plutôt les scènes
avec des dauphins
tout cela nourrit certains franchement
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est ce qu'un boycott sur twitter à ce
qu'un déchet ces multinationales rouler
à 30 voulait détruits dont 6,1 l'an
prochain alors ma soeur bénabar michel
mais tu pouvais mais attention à toi tu
en auras à ce que l'on roule à d'autres
heures sur twitter tout de suite c'est
un sondage express à taussat sondage
express c'est merci à ses partisans
pendant qu'ils étaient en vacances au
bord de la mer il paraît vous prenez des
bannis à jamais sa part à minuit pile de
temps en temps vous n'aimez pas ça pas
trop y avait tous assis tout seul seul
effectivement il est temps ça va à peu
près bien et je pense que c'est assez
bien là je suis entend le sport vous
pratiquez séquelles jamais monter à
cheval
non elle est si jolie
[Applaudissements]
ok attention c'est parti
bonsoir bonsoir donc tu as un scoop
alors jamais ouais c'est prochaine ce
soir ce scoop exact géniale idée
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le dernier ça va être notre ami julien
courbet je vis je me demandais des fêtes
de rodez mais toi la place de bojan est
bien meilleure celle là vous avez
surpris vous habite à la place de la
vierge et bien vous vous appuyez parce
que ça lui fait plaisir
voyons pas voulu appuyer si ça plaît
venez ça on est là on dirait qu'elle a
fait une course à la tendance cheval
excusez moi d'être mode super et bien
c'est très simple des boutons tapis tu
sais quoi je me dis que ça fait mal non
allez-y jean-pierre way attention
pendant huit heures non-stop départ
bonsoir bonsoir notre jeu jouer tu de ce
jeu jamais vous êtes sur une page unique
france semble c'était aux prises deux
joueurs moi me souviens qu'à paris et
les acteurs aussi dans toute évidence et
j'adore dans seize ans il a bien tiré
mais jeff à mesure qu du jazz le jazz
aussi le hip hop qui rêvait aubry n'a
jamais le reggaeton touareg et hop c'est
bien ça me sens très bien drayton
voulait fera pas avec moi vous bloquez
oui jamais sur un détendez-vous sera là
je le dis jamais vous avez la bande
depuis longtemps aux six mois ce que je
peux m'approcher de bouffer fatto que je
vois pas je sais pas trop preda pas du
tout marié j'adore quand vous êtes près
de moi vous êtes jaloux basale ou non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on fait le garder avec d'autres a dit et
je suis accroupi derrière
très vite alors attention je sais pas
alors julien a torché partir ce que
depuis très longtemps julien depuis 15
ans depuis quinze ans c'était donc à
l'époque lointaine
c'était à l'époque de sacrée soirée avec
louvain gérard louvet et jean pierre
foucault et tu commences 7 watts été
jetés jeunes débuté au début tu te
souviens pas du tout jeune avait
dissuadé kenza faire date et les plus
tard effectivement tenir mon bureau où
tu me disent ah oui
[Musique]
c'est la pire des crises les personnes
malades et handicapées
merci